here's a nice Investments question a sum
amounts to 3 600 at two percent per
annum under simple interest and 4 800 at
four percent per annum under simple
interest the time of the investment is
blank years
to work out simple interest you take the
principal and multiply it by the
interest rate to get the amount of
Interest per year you get the same
amount of interest for every one of the
T years of investment so the total
amount of interest is p times R times T
you add the initial principle to get the
ending value
now we don't know the principle or the
time but we do know the final value and
the interest rate so we substitute in
for the known information and we get two
equations in two variables p and t we
solve these equations by dividing
through this eliminates the P variable
we simplify the fraction then we can
cross multiply to get a single equation
in t now distribute and group like terms
and divide to get that t is equal to 25
years